ladies and gentlemen mr. Cecil B DeMille
readings from Hollywood ladies and
gentlemen this year your acclaim and the
vote of this Academy have nominated five
outstanding pictures for the best motion
picture of 1953 From Here to Eternity
Columbia produced by buddy Adler Julius
Caesar metro-goldwyn-mayer produced by
John Houseman
the robe what if the robe by 20th
Century Fox
produced by Frank Ross Roman Holiday
Paramount produced by william whele shan
paramount produced by george stevens the
envelope lisa and the winner is from
here to eternity
motion picture industry in the year of
1953 presented some of the great
pictures of our industry I'm proud to be
part of that industry and I'm singularly
honored by the members of the Academy
for selecting from here to eternity as
the best picture of the year in the army
of the United States for their great
cooperation today and tarish a great
script Freddie's in ermine inspired
direction to Harry Cohn president
Columbia Pictures my grateful thanks for
his confidence and trust in me and to
the many other associates thank you
thank you
many gentlemen and at this point thank
you we would like to express our thanks
but also like to express our thanks to
O's 'mobile